con el lema este sitio salvavidas
escrito en la entrada nueva york abre el
primer centro de inyección de drogas en
eeuu un esfuerzo en la lucha contra la
sobredosis que sólo en 2020 mataron a
más de dos mil personas en la ciudad
básicamente uno de los modelos si es si
vas a consumir si vas a seguir
consumiendo déjanos enseñarte a consumir
de forma segura habitaciones con
jeringuillas personal sanitarios
desfibriladores los consumidores de
sustancias acuden al centro para
drogarse de forma segura pero allí
también les ofrecen atención médica
lavandería comida caliente y asesorías
[Música]
los llevan a una habitación especial y
en la sala hay entre 2 y 3 miembros del
personal con formación médica por si
algo va mal tienen habitaciones
separadas para los fumadores de crack
cabinas con espejos con iluminación
completa para los usuarios de
inyecciones full aire
a nivel nacional las muertes por
sobredosis aumentaron a más de 100.000
el año pasado la mayoría relacionadas
con sobredosis de fentanilo y otras
sustancias sintéticas
estamos en un punto increíblemente malo
en el que hemos tenido el mayor aumento
de muertes en eeuu y en canadá
añadiría en la historia de cualquiera de
estos países
por ello las organizaciones quieren
poner en la agenda política el consumo
de sustancias ilícitas y tratarlo como
un asunto de salud pública sin embargo
la ley federal todavía describe las
actividades de estas instalaciones como
ilegales pese a estos esfuerzos la
controversia en torno a estos servicios
que salvan vidas sigue polarizando a la
sociedad